WELLE: Can you pull all
the way to the front, sir?
MAN: Sure.
WELLE: Thank you.
Right there is good.
And then everybody
step out and, uh,
just sit over by that
table over there please.
Thank you.
If you can think of
putting something in something,
you'll find it
here at San Ysidro.
They get really creative
'cause they wanna maximize
their profits as
best as they can,
so it's a constant
game of hide and seek.
(knocks)
There's all sorts of different
nooks and crannies in a truck,
especially a big one like this,
that you can hide something.
We like to check, um, everywhere
in the engine compartment,
the quarter panels, tires,
under the vehicle as well.
The trends change as to where
people hide things in their car,
so it's always good
to be very thorough.
OFFICER: All clear.
WELLE: Um, you
guys are good to go.
Thank you.
It was negative, so
they were released, uh,
to enjoy the rest of their day.
FRANCO: So this
vehicle was selected for
secondary inspection at
the vehicle primary lane.
We are gonna do a
K9 inspection on it.
OFFICER: There's
something there, huh?
Good boy. Good boy.
FRANCO: At this point,
it was a K9 hit.
Therefore, we are gonna do a
seven-point vehicle inspection
on it and then we'll go
from there to see what we find.
OFFICER: Spot back here.
FRANCO: Which one?
You wanna pop it?
(thudding)
There you go.
OFFICER: Yeah.
(thudding)
OFFICER: If there's
something in there,
we're gonna have to
go in there and get it.
(radio chatter)
(thudding)
FRANCO: There's
some tampering here.
So right now we're just
trying to figure out and
how to get into this area.
OFFICER: It's missing a lug nut.
OFFICER 2: You can tell
it was recently taken off.
And there's fingerprints
all along the side, right?
So you can tell
it's recently been done.
The compartment may be
located behind the tire.
It's the only access is
through the wheel well.
FRANCO: Since it seems
to be like there's some
deep concealment
in that trunk area,
we're gonna go
ahead and take the car
to one of our secure areas,
where we'll go ahead
and lift the vehicle up and
get underneath there and
actually get in there deeper
to find that
narcotic concealment.